do you think that jihad needs you i know
that the jihad doesn't need me
but i need it are you thinking
we should do that with the help of
violence are you convinced at this point
never hate so intensely and never loved
so intensely
uh volunteers who came from all over the
world were about 900 we buried 350 there
it was a very peaceful religion
is that kind of what you're saying islam
is not a religion of peace and islam
basically by the way is one of the most
capitalistic
in a free market religions you could
ever find the embassy
was actually a front for the cia
[Music]
so you know a lot of people have lived
interesting lives but some tells me
today's
guest has lived maybe a little bit more
of an interesting life you'll find out
here in a second when i tell you
this man went from being part of al
qaeda yes
al qaeda in 1996 he met osama bin laden
for the
first time you'll kind of hear how that
process takes uh takes place and in
december 98 he leaves and he goes from
al-qaeda
to joining mi6 and he writes a book the
title of the book is
nine lives my time as mi6
top spy inside al qaeda with that being
said
i'm ending thank you so much for being a
guest on vapetainment thank you for
having me
so you've lived a quite uh you know
interesting life there
that that that qualifies for interesting
i sure hope so yeah so
so can you take us back and kind of tell
me about your upbringing
where you grew up at so the audience
knows obviously i got all the notes here
in front of me
but if you don't mind taking a moment
and sharing with that and then how
or how you got recruited into al qaeda i
think that'd be a good way to start
well i can say that i was more of the
typical middle eastern salad
you know if you could say it that way
like because i uh
was a bahraini uh national uh
born in saudi arabia to a father who was
born in iraq you know to and his mother
was
a half turkish half greek jewish and my
mother was from lebanon
so you know i end up basically like i
mean being a true middle eastern
um you know uh mix uh to the point where
i remember when i looked at my dna
many many years later i found that um 40
from the middle east 30 from persia uh
from turkey and the caucuses you know
and about 10
12 from the indian subcontinent
including afghanistan
so i used to i i thought wow what a mix
but nonetheless if you grew up in saudi
arabia in the 1980s
and you you know you will be growing up
in a society that was
deeply deeply conservative sunni muslim
um and where i lived actually was a mix
of shia and sundays because i lived in
the
uh eastern part of the country so
and i lived in the most um
divisive era you could ever imagine
imagine that my mother
was from lebanon so she was worried
about the lebanese civil war
that was taking place in her mother
country
uh at the same time just few hundred
kilometers away to the north
uh iraq was locked in a deadly war with
iran
uh for eight years from 1980 until 1988.
uh so in our school i remember i was
living in iran at that time when that
was going on in tehran 80 to 88 it was
not pretty it was ugly
exactly so i remember where i
grew up in our school uh one
one third of the uh students were
shia and two-thirds were sunnis so
it was almost like supporting two
opposing football teams
so the sunnis will support saddam
hussein and iraq
and the shia will be supporting
iran and ayatollah khomeini so you know
and of course for us kids it was very
strange i mean
how uh would you desensitize war to the
point where basically like you know you
view it as a contest
in between two teams and you make it so
sectarian
you know that you know we are all saudis
or gulf people there
and yet we were supporting different uh
sides of the war according to our
uh sectarian preferences so
if that doesn't politicize a young child
at such young age i don't know what
would uh
do actually um and then
you know ironically the man who we
supported the man who we were cheering
up for
saddam hussein in uh august of uh
1990 decided to stab us in the back well
actually the front
uh moved into kuwait um and as a result
my city hubbard was the first major
city from the kuwaiti border so three
hours drive from the kuwaiti border
we started to see what i would call in
1990 the
richest caravan of refugees you could
ever imagine imagine refugees
coming in bmws mercedes
cadillac's you know it was a
weird sight to see people who wore
same arabic dresses as us they spoke the
same accent
uh almost the same tribal uh makeup
and yet they were running away from the
person who until two months ago we were
cheering up
you know calling him the um you know the
hero of the arab world uh the guardian
of the eastern gate as
you know the arabs used to call him um
and
you know he basically stabbed us you
know basically in
front and back um and that of course
resulted in
a massive international effort uh
to expel him how that happened well
from seeing rich refugees coming into my
city i started seeing
many american soldiers landing in my
city
because my city also was the host of the
largest
uh military air base in the entire
middle east
king abdul aziz air base so i mean i
was seeing you know hundreds of u.s
humvees
and uh you know armored vehicles just
going around
uh these american soldiers were very
approachable very friendly
they were what year is this one year
got it okay of course they were that
year they were friendly they were not
yet
they haven't yet faced the uh uh you
know the hostility that
grew up with the guy that basically of
the later 1990s and so
they were even lining up uh in the
fast food chains in order to order
burgers and fries and all of that and
they were just happy to mingle with the
local population because for us we saw
them as
the protectors from a impending
uh iraqi invasion that saddam hussein
wanted to control
the oil wells and the oil wealth
of the gulf and therefore we were afraid
we would be next after kuwait
the presence of the american soldiers
and the american forces
was a reassuring presence but at the
same time
i was a religious kid my religious
leaders at the time were opposing
completely the presence of the american
troops
uh they were saying that it is
completely against the spirit of islam
that in the arabian peninsula an army of
half a million christian soldiers
are present this is not what was
supposed to happen
and therefore they were they are
supposed to be expelled rather than
being invited
now this is where the first
you know uh took place you know in my
mindset i was by the time 11
uh going on 12 and i was already
heavily politicized uh kid because of
everything that was happening around me
and i asked you at that time when you're
11 years old about to be 12
in your mind who's america who's iran
who's israel in your mind for us
iran was the sectarian threat
um israel was the occupier of the holy
sites
um america was the big
bully you know kid on the block but with
cool gadgets
that's how we viewed america at the time
okay
yeah so so please continue you're 11
years old about to be 12 years old
exactly so for me you know i started to
become more confused about what to
believe anymore i mean
you know should i cheer the american
presence
um and the fact that they will be
not only defending us against a
potential invasion by saddam hussein but
also expel saddam hussein out of kuwait
because for us
still the arafi invasion of kuwait was
unjust and he is not supposed to have
invaded kuwait and therefore he need to
be expelled uh
and that is i think where um
at that time i was in reading a leaflet
i saw in one of the mosques that leaflet
was
saying that it was a big historical
mistake on uh you know uh
with catastrophic proportions that we
have allowed the americans to come in
the solution was to raise an army of
jihadists an
army of mujahideen to push back saddam
hussein from kuwait
who signed that pamphlet which i saw in
that mosque
osama bin laden and that was the first
time i heard
and i read the name osama bin laden that
he is one of the leaders of the
arab jihadists in afghanistan fighting
against the soviets and then later the
communist regime in kabul
and he was opposed to it opposed to the
presence of american forces
um and he was talking about the fact
that you can't have
an american christian army
present in the um holy
sanctified land of arabia although i was
wondering there is nothing holy about my
city i mean yes there is mecca medina
that's holy but the rest of it is not
however you know for osama bin laden and
for
many of those who were like-minded
including
the leaders of the muslim brotherhood in
saudi arabia the other hybrid group
you know which is the hybrid salafis
wahhabis and muslim brotherhood
groups they were not exactly happy
with the presence of the american forces
they believed basically that the
solution should come from within
uh you know the so-called muslim ummah
or the muslim nation
um however i was thinking at the time
how could the solution come from within
the muslim um when many parts of the
so-called muslim nation
were actually supporting saddam hussein
including
for god's sake as well as you know the
leaders of yemen and sudan
um that is i think where um you know my
mind
was spinning around faster than
you know i could actually comprehend in
terms of
who to believe and what to follow
nonetheless the war
the gulf war took place in january of
and for us it was the first televised
war and this is the first time ever
in my life i saw cnn so
at the time cnn was the
network station that broadcasted the war
live for everyone to see whether from
baghdad
uh or from you know the uh
even our own city which was due to the
presence of the air base
uh subject to a squad missile attack by
the arabi uh forces
and of course basically it's the first
time we um
we you know we were subject to air raid
sirens
um we have to put the gas masks on
ourselves
because we were suspecting that we would
be attacked by chemical weapons
that the missiles are carrying chemical
warheads we were of course
living through a nightmare and that is i
think where
my first experience of war it was not as
brutal as
those who experienced it of course in
baghdad
and other iraqi cities but nonetheless
it was the first time i felt what it
feels like
to be subject of an attack by such
sophisticated weaponry but
also glad for the american air defense
network the patriot system which
shot down the vast majority of those
missiles before they reach the ground
although near the end i remember i was
at the roof of my house
when i saw one of the missiles in a
basically landing
just only 800 meters from my house and
it hit a barracks
you know a building where 28 american
soldiers were killed
um uh due to that attack so i remember i
saw all the ambulances going and i saw
dozens of them the firefighters and
heard the news
and somehow it made me sad
um you know the death of the soldiers
and that was i think the last time
the death of american soldiers made me
sad for many years to come because
at later life i became so radical in my
thoughts
that i would end up celebrating the
death of american soldiers
how did that how did that indoctrination
take place
what were events that got you to believe
in the fact that you should celebrate
rather than mourn over the loss of uh
american lives
what happened there how did you get
recruited who changed your way of
thinking
two events in particular i would say um
the first event
uh was personal um
at the age of 12 just uh months after
the end of the gulf war
my mother passed away she was only 49 at
that time it was a brain aneurysm
uh it was sudden um just as brain
aneurysm is
you know as it goes undetected um
and that's it she collapsed two days
later she died
um and for me of course as a young
religious kid at that time
for me it was all about finding answers
i was the youngest of my brothers you
know so it helped that there were older
brothers
in the house who would you know more or
less offer some comfort and support uh
my dad already was dead when i was four
so basically like you know for me
uh the passing of my mother was you know
the loss of the last
i would say moral compass that
stabilizing factor that anchor that like
actually keeps you safe and secure and
grounded
unfortunately that was gone and for me i
drifted into
uh if for example kids when they have
some freedom usually like you know
basically they will use that freedom
towards um
you know going out with their you know
with their uh friends
hanging out smoking you know doing
something like you know basically
whatever for me
i was more of a nerdish you know kid
more into books and so the drifting was
more
subtle more political and ideological
and religious
and i ended up basically looking into uh
ways to find solace and uh
how can i say you know consoling
basically in
um religious texts and one of my
teachers at the time
said to me that there is a book that
if you read it could help you deal with
your grief
and i said to him what is that he said
there is a book written
by a egyptian ideologue
and a thinker his name is saying
say it of course basically had a great
impact
not only on my country but yours also
you know basically in iran
uh because uh you know he actually his
writings were translated
by the current ayatollah when he was
imprisoned
and it provided the framework of
political islam to take shape
in iran and then later in other islamic
movements across the arab muslim world
and so for me
i was told that i should read his books
what is the book i was supposed to read
a book called
in the shades of the quran it is
four thousand pages written over nine
years period
and all of these nine years this book
was written between the
years of 1954 and 1963
when sayyid kotov was in jail in egypt
and the egyptian jails in the 1950s and
60s were not exactly a picnic
i mean it was a horror show to say the
least
so he wrote his interpretation he's
literally um interpreting interpretation
of the quran
from the prison of pain grief
and torture and darkness and loneliness
and grief you know so his commentary on
the quran
was while beautiful in its words
and imagery and literary value
it was really all geared towards
one aim and one goal as he always keep
repeating this
it is to establish the kingdom of god
on earth as he ordained it to be
so the you know this concept of god's
kingdom on earth
and that it needs to be achieved through
violence
you know if necessary which is jihad in
order to
achieve a pure islamic society
that would drive away most of the grief
and the pain
and the suffering that we are
experiencing because of the
disillusionment and the ill governance
that is taking place in the arab muslim
all the
remember he was opposing he was a
socialist at early stages of his life
he dabbled in communism then later he
became an islamist
opposing both capitalism and socialism
and communism so basically he
arrived at the conclusion that only
islamism
could offer a salvation a solution
to the muslim masses that are yearning
for justice
that is satan so i ended up between the
ages of 12
to the age of 14 reading
the writings of seekbottom and basically
being influenced so heavily how do you
spell his name
which is
and this book he wrote you said four
thousand pages he wrote in eight nine
years of being in jail in egypt in the
fifties to 60s
and pro was you said prior to that he
was a communist and a
communist to socialist to
okay so in that process would you who
would you compare him to was he like the
was he like the karl marx minus the jail
was he like the
figurehead of sharing some of those
philosophies with the people
what what what who would you compare him
to i i think in my opinion he was a
revolutionary
uh thinker who basically for the first
time ever
um such a you know like karl marx and
others basically who advocated the
violence of the overthrow of the
bourgeoisie governments by the
oppressed proletariats he advocated
the you know violent revolution
by the masses to throw away the unjust
an islamic rule you know across the
muslim world and replacing it with
islamic
sharia-based rule what he called it the
kingdom of god on earth
a semi-utopian society you know
that is subject to god's laws but is
governed by
men of god that's how he
uh saw the evolution of
societies in the muslim and arab world
into a unified
super islamic structure which is the
caliphate
the kingdom of god on earth and he was
the first one who advocated
that since you know uh
violence or the deployment of violence
throughout islamic history was the
prerogative of the state
never the individual he is the first one
to actually advocate the deployment
of violence by individuals to overthrow
the state
and to replace it with a islamic state
wow
so here's what it says here about him it
says even though most of his
observations and criticism were leveled
at the muslim world kutep is also known
for his intense disapproval of the
society and culture of the united states
which he saw as materialistic
and obsessed with violence and sexual
pleasures he advocated violence
offensive jihad kutep has also been
described by his followers as a great
thinker
and martyr of islam while many western
observers and some muslims see him as ki
original originator of islamist ideology
and then ask for
inspiration for violent islamic groups
such as
al qaeda today his supporters are
identified by his opponents as
coutibists
or could be is what they described him
so let me ask you when you read this as
a kid
um at that point was he already did he
already have a lot of influence he's
written 30 books
you know he's been around the block was
he already an influential figure or not
yet when you first read it
he was he was an influential figure no
question because you see
uh president nasser of egypt executed
him in 1966
so what he said before he died which is
a very famous quotes by
quote by him he said our words
remain dead candles with no life
until we die for these words and then
they are lit and they are alive and
therefore basically he believed
that by dying he will seal his legend
that's why you know when he you know
when he was
uh you know about to be hanged you know
they brought a uh a cleric
you know to remind him you know to uh
say the words you know basically before
he dies which is
there is no god but god so he said
you know to the uh cleric i die
this word while you eat bread with that
word
so the man knew what he was doing he was
stealing his legend
to make sure that his revolutionary
ideas will become even
more intense and more credible because
he died for them
he knew what he was doing strategic and
by the way he was hung because
he was conspired to assassinate the
president so
you know that was your concerns about
but but let me ask you when you read the
book
at this time when you first read it
you're how old 12 years old 13 years old
yeah between the ages of 12 and 14. so
when you read this book the first time
4 000 pages what are you thinking
when you're done reading it are you
thinking this guy makes sense i want to
go bring the kingdom of god on earth are
you thinking
we should do that with the help of
violence are you convinced at this point
by the time yes because it wasn't just
the book but also
the background of the society i was
living in
already there was the post uh
iraq war um and the agitation by the
followers of the saiyan the clerics i
used to listen to
the um you know just like uh ayatollah
khomeini in iran when he was using the
cassette
you know as the uh medium through which
he was able to communicate with the
masters the fast
very effective exactly the first social
media
you know that's right uh you know to
make sure that people who are taking
taxes
you know would listen to uh his sermons
it's the same thing the cassette was the
medium through these clerics were
disseminating
you know their you know revolutionary
ideas
about the fact that saudi arabia for
them was not muslim enough can you
believe it like
i mean for them saudi arabia which was a
wahhabist
you know salafist uh closed muslim
conservative society was not good enough
even
and therefore there was the need to
overthrow them
just like the shah was overthrown and
therefore
we need to do it i was so convinced at
the time because
uh one on one hand i was reading this
book and
getting all of these ideas and on the
second hand
i was also listening to these clerics on
the you know from their cassettes
listening to their lectures and sermons
talking about the need
for islamic solidarity islamic awakening
islamic renaissance and the need to go
from the repetitive the boring
the you know the you know and this lack
of lack of dynamism as they pulled it
into a more dynamic you know muslim
society that can
actually challenge the powers of the
world of the time
however that wasn't the only reason why
maharadicalization
you know happened there was another
event you know uh
that also led me towards you know the
jihad and the path of the
jihad which was the bosnian conflict
which was you know raging in 1992 at the
time i was 14.
so it just started and at that time
the uh you know my local mosque the
local charity that
i used to belong to started to collect
uh funds to help the muslims of bosnia
who
were of course subject to the civil wars
and the horrors of the civil war that
were taking place in the former yoga
yoga staff republics bosnia you know was
a country where
the muslims made up about uh half of the
population the other half was
divided between serbs and karate they
voted for independence
from yugoslavia that led to the subs of
the country declaring war on the
uh muslim majority and as a result
uh ethnic cleansing started to take
place now
these events were portrayed
unfortunately and wrongly
um in the saudi media and the
arab world you know intellectual
discourse
as a war between christianity and islam
because the serbs
invoked christian symbology
while in fact they were fighting a
ethnic
nationalistic uh war that had
nothing to do basically with
christianity they were actually killing
you know uh their you know fellow
christians who were crowds
um you know you know of course basically
it was a sectarian base because the
serbs were orthodox were catholics
but nonetheless like you know even the
karmas were subject to ethnic cleansing
and they were not muslims basically they
were christians but it was
portrayed this way in our media and our
religious discourse
in saudi arabia and the rest of the arab
muslim world
so suddenly we are not only collecting
funds to help
you know the muslims there um
withstand the onslaught of the subs
suddenly we started to see people from
our community including a teacher of
mine
at school who was a math teacher for my
affluent
family would travel there with a member
of the bahraini royal family
uh both of them would die there over the
summer of 1992
and fighting alongside the bosnians
against the serbs
and suddenly you know we started to hear
that
you know a few words put together in one
sentence
jihad martyrdom and sacrifice
all in one word and suddenly the bosnian
conflict which was raging
um you know 3 000 miles away
where it was in fact present in our own
classroom
because our teacher is missing you know
our math teacher is missing but he was
killed in action in bosnia
uh he's a saudi you know from the saudi
deserts
has nothing to do with the um lush
european mountains of the balkans
but that islamic solidarity and that
sense of islamic duty towards
oppressed muslim minority more or less
ignited that need in him to go and fight
the jihad so i was asking myself
if my teacher can do it why can't i
and two years later when i became 16
the catalyst for that event happened
when
uh one of my friends even though he was
three years my senior
he was actually going to join the jihad
in bosnia i learned
from his brother that he was leaving so
when i was going to his home
you know to say goodbye
i ended up knocking in his door and
instead of saying goodbye i was saying
i want to come with you and i remember
like i mean he was
you know even though he was 19 you know
he himself was young but he was telling
me
since i'm 16 i just became 16 four days
ago you know since you're 16 you can't
go like
i mean jihad is not a picnic he was
telling me even for god's sake you are
only 16.
do you know what jihad is you know
people will necessarily die they could
actually
get wounded bullets bullet holes
amputations
you know you could step on a mine and
lose your leg you know it's not a picnic
do you think that jihad needs you i
remember what
you know that my answer changed his mind
and changed my own life i said to him
khalid i know that the jihad doesn't
need me
but i need it i
want to go ah you know i need it for my
own betterment
i don't want to be a spectator on the
you know uh
you know on you know on the seats
basically watching the caravan of
history passing me by
wishing that i you know made my own you
know
writings on the pages of history no i
wanted to be part of it i don't want to
be a spectator anymore that's it
um and that changed his mind and he
decided to take me with him and
um uh two weeks later we were in vienna
you know on our way to bosnia during
your time as a
you know when you went to bosnia and as
well as once you joined al qaeda what
are some things you witnessed yourself
well where to start liking i mean uh i
think the right question is
what did what didn't i witness um you
know in the sense like i mean you see
everything once you are in a
uh a war a brutal war like bosnia i mean
you see mass graves you see the child
remains of villages
uh you see uh destroyed mosques
destroyed churches
uh you see you know prisoner exchanges
where
instead of seeing prisoners you know who
are wearing military uniforms
and uh you know big you know hairy men
instead you see children being exchanged
you know basically like
i mean who were you know in the camps
you know being
held prisoners you see young 14 year
olds who were held for two years
as captives and you hear the horror
stories basically of them being
great you know you see a lot of this
because of the hatred the deep hatred
that was
beneath the surface between the
communities there
and this is a warning to many people
across the world
you know is never
hate so intensely and never love so
intensely you never know who will be
your enemies one day and who will be
your friends when they
moderation and everything basically is
the key towards
longevity of any society um
you know so this is exactly what i've
seen um you know and of course basically
you know when we went to bosnia we were
four we left bosnia we were two
because we buried two of our you know
friends uh back
i mean the number of the uh volunteers
who came from all over the world were
about 900 we burned 350 there
um so so so basically like i mean the
life expectancy was really short for
anyone who was there
um i was wounded in action there you
know basically although it was a mild
one
i you know basically have seen for my
eyes like in a
you know as a 16 year old things that in
a well a 16 year old shouldn't have
witnessed like you know but then what
made me resilient
is that i've seen the 13 and the 14 and
the 11 and the nine-year-olds
you know basically who've seen the
horrors of paul being more resilient
and that basically gives me hope you
know basically that if they can
um put up with it if they can go through
it then i can
amen let me ask you uh first time you
met osama bin laden how old were you
well it was um just before my
uh 18th birthday it was august uh the
first week of august of 1996.
um you know so i was about to become 18
in about
maybe like i mean five weeks six weeks
um
you know i by that time i was in
afghanistan you know the whole scene
shifted now
bosnia uh was over the war was over
there
and uh on the advice uh
in bosnia where i met him on the advice
of the mastermind of 9 11
muhammad when he came to visit us in
bosnia his advice was
go to afghanistan get training and
prepare for the
next phase of the war the camps are
reopening
so i followed his advice after a brief
detour
to the caucuses and i ended up in
afghanistan in 96
so two months after my arrival or three
months
i think um osama bin laden returned
from sudan where he was in exile there
to afghanistan
and you know where we were
training in our training camp his
location was only 45 minutes drive away
um so we heard that he was asking around
if there are any people from
uh the arabian peninsula he never wanted
to say saudi arabia
you know because he always believed that
the house of saud was illegitimate so he
was saying
the arabian peninsula so you know 14 of
us
uh decided to go and see him um
and when he went to see him he was a
guest at the compound
uh belonged to one of the uh warlords of
afghanistan his name was eunice palace
and i remember when when when we entered
the compound
we saw so many people who were egyptians
and some people from
uh sudan libya algeria as well as
himself
originally from saudi arabia um but what
we saw wasn't impressive
you know they looked like refugees
wasn't or it was
it wasn't impressive it wasn't at all
okay it you know you see the problem is
many people when they ask me the
question
how was it you know their first time you
know seeing osama bin laden and people
expect me to say oh wow it was so
impressive no it wasn't
and the reason is because everyone's in
the world everyone in the world
their impression of osama bin laden is
that neat
white turban with uh in a white
clean well-ironed robes you know looking
so
you know uh clean and tidy um
no that wasn't how i saw somebody the
first time
he wore very creased robes and an arabic
headscarf over his head that was at
all seeing an iron for weeks actually
and he looked really disheveled and as
if basically he was just lucky to escape
with his life
so you know the first impression wasn't
the best impression to be honest
um but nonetheless you know
um when we sat in front of him all 14 of
us
and of course he had his lieutenants
around him including abu hafree
who was his deputy we sat in front of
him to understand
why he returned back from sudan of
course he was betrayed by the sudanese
leadership
and expelled but nonetheless he
spoke um about the divine
mission that he is you know embarking on
the divine
path laid in front of him because he was
believing that
it was destiny it was faith that brought
him
from sudan all the way back to
afghanistan to enact
god's plans in the old ancient
prophecies of islam
regarding the armies of the black
banners you know
and the victorious vanguard sweeping
from afghanistan
all the way to jerusalem all the way to
the arabian peninsula
you know paving the way for you know
the fictional imam mahdi you know which
is a messiah figure in
islamic imagination uh in order
you know to fill the world with justice
after it was filled with
injustice now um
he saw but by the way isabella was great
at reading minds
he would basically look at your face and
we'll see
you know whether you are a believer a
skeptical
you know whether you you know are really
going along with the flow or are you not
like exactly like i mean understanding
what he's saying
so he looked at our faces and he could
tell that some of us were really
skeptical
um you know really are we the
you know fulfillment of the prophecies
so
he said you might see us right now
as bunch of refugees you know people
basically who just arrived
you know escaping and lucky to be
escaped with our lives
you know it was a miracle actually that
we made it without being caught
you know here in afghanistan but he said
remember
that when the prophet muhammad he
escaped medina
so he escaped on the night of his
migration
and a flight to medina
while he was escaping the arab tribes
were hunting him
and the arab knights were you know
hunting him because basically they
wanted to win the bounty on his head
um one of the arab nights when he
finally approached him his horse
fell broke his legs and he was stumbling
on the ground
so he thought that muhammad used one of
his magic tricks
so he said you know uh you know to the
prophet
i can't let you just go to medina i have
to you know bring you back and so the
prophet said well if you
let us go then i promise you something
i promise you that you will be wearing
the
crown and the bracelets of the persian
emperor
so you know that arab knight said what
are you out of your mind like
i mean you are a fugitive in the desert
you know of the arabian desert like in
basically and you are threatening the
might of persia
you know so he said yes i promise you
that you will be wearing
in the crown and the bracelets of the
persian emperor he said put it to
writing
so the prophet instructed his companion
to you know write it for him give him
the
parchment sealed with his seal and
that's it so 16 years later
you know that arab night was actually
wearing you know
uh the crown and the bracelets of the
persian emperor after the conquest of
uh tessapan um and i think in the year
uh 6 36 80 or 67 a.d so
busan of aladdin used that incident to
say
never ever underestimate what we can do
here we can change history
if we believe in ourselves the same way
that the prophet did
ironically he did change history
when his operatives slammed those
airplanes into the
world trade center and the pentagon and
the us
so this is the mindset
of osama bin laden the combative
fanatical believing mindset
of osama bin laden just days after he
arrived
in afghanistan from sudan next to me
his knee touching my knee was a man
called abu ubaidah
abu ubaidah a young saudi spectacled
with thick glasses
two years exactly on the fourth of
august of 1998
two years after that he was so
mesmerized of course by osama bin
laden's
talk he went on to drive the ban
to the american embassy in nairobi
so um and that of course exploded with
you know a considerable number of
casualties
you know 220 plus people were killed uh
including 12 americans
and as well as 5 000 people wounded 150
of them were blinded for life
this is the effect of fanatical
eschatological
prophetic words that osama bin laden
you know you know basically delivered
into our minds
you know basically and they had the
effect of
toxins and they were toxic that's the
guy that was sitting right next to you
that drove the van into the american
embassy in nairobi
exactly sitting right next to you let me
let me ask you a question
uh from your
uh uh you know research on him and
knowing him
now over the years you've had access to
a lot of different information yourself
and you've done your own research you've
been around it what
what what things did osama bin laden
admire
was he also a guy who admired syed
because i just looked up an article
while you were speaking the
uh how khomeini read the book that syed
wrote three years after
uh he was assassinated and in 1984 even
in iran
he sent some a postcard showing the
frowning face of syed behind prison bars
before his execution he issued a
postcard khomeini did in 84.
so that was his inspiration right who
was
bin laden's inspiration a guy that he
looked up to
outside of prophet muhammad in the quran
who else was it
well of course it was said no question
about it
for him was the inspiration because he
is the first
to call for an islamic revolution by the
masses it never happened before in
islamic history
throughout islamic history you know and
just to let you know for example
muhammad was in fact
the last cleric you know if we can you
know use this word to describe him
to be the ruler of a society because
his successors after that were never
from the clergy
or the class of the clergy you know abu
bakr was a merchant
you know the first scale of omar was a
merchant uh usman was a supermarket
actually and
ali was a judge and a warrior um and if
you look at uh
you know all those who followed in the
dynastic um
you know uh empires like the umayyads
and the abbasids and the ottomans they
were all dynastic rulers
you know without any uh you know
clerical
or let's say basically religious um in
upbringing themselves
you know so therefore you know the idea
that
islam you know or islamic societies
should be ruled
by those who basically are clerics or
members of the clergy
is an anesthma to the islamic spirit
itself
um and this is why you know
the um you know the
is the first to break away from that you
know to break away from the idea that
the islamic or the muslim masses should
obey their
secular rulers that the muslim masses
have no right to deploy violence against
the state
that only the state has the right to
deploy violence and the protection of
the state
from enemies within the society and from
outside
so he broke away completely like i mean
he you know he thrown out all of these
you know conventions uh you know outside
of the window altogether
and decided to come up with an ideology
that is similar to communism you know in
other words basically he
appropriated islam in a communistic
fashion because he was actually a
communist before
to revolutionize it in a way that
enables the masses the individuals
to carry out arms against the state
in order to replace it and to bring
about
islamic sovereignty you see if you look
at
you know shira islam jihad is almost
absent there because jihad is only the
prerogative of the imam
and since the imam is absent therefore
the
you know the jihad is absent for sunni
islam
there are two kinds of jihad you know
the defense of jihad
you know if your society is overwhelmed
by an enemy you know take up arms and
defend yourself
self-defense that's understood however
the offense of jihad
the uh conquest jihad was which
unfortunately
many muslims feel ashamed of and try to
brush it under the
carpet you know and say oh it doesn't
exist it exists i'm sorry to say that in
about
thousands you know of books basically i
can explain the concept
and it exists there i mean and there is
nothing
to be ashamed about conquest i mean
every empire did it
you know throughout history from the
romans you know basically to the
byzantines to the chinese to the indian
empires
and in the british french empire
everyone did conquest that's fine
but you know islam as religion actually
did sunni islam did in fact
put together in a theology of conquest
jihad
and however that conquest jihad is
only the prerogative of the head of the
state
only a state can sanction that
now came after all these years after
1350 years of solid theology
to come and say no no no no no we have
a third kind of jihad is called jihad
or the jihad of sovereignty the
sovereignty jihad to restore islam to
sovereignty to the position where it
belongs
so i mean you know just like with
suicide bombings just like with many
other aspects of
modern jihadism there is a clear
departure
from the old agreed upon islamic
principles
you know you know and uh you know this
is why like
when people say that modern-day
jihadists like you basically are really
you know having twisted many of the
interpretations of islam it is true to
some extent
actually because they did actually
invent quite new
uh forms of theology just to justify
their revolutionary ideas that they are
you know basically
supporting and propagating would you
would you consider yourself a muslim
today
uh yes um at the end of the day thank
god like you know islam
has you know more than 70 different
schools of thought um
i would consider myself a hybrid between
uh sufi and salafi although like you
know some people will say what
but you know i view islam basically as a
spiritual anchor um a something yeah
who's prophet muhammad to you who's
prophet muhammed to you
a teacher a teacher who's who's jesus to
you
um a divine prophet
got it uh who's salman rushdie to you
and what he wrote about
in his satanic verses huh um i would say
a very mediocre writer
a very mediocre writer yeah i didn't
read the book
yeah what do you think about it um
basically like i mean um the writing
wasn't great
um you know basically but he based his
uh
writing on you know basically a a story
that was uh happened during the time of
the prophet
then he took it and took extreme liberty
with it in order basically to
embellish it with imagery and with
intrigue
and with um you know uh how can i say
like a
representation of arab society at the
time you know
uh but i know i didn't you know while i
didn't find it
um you know basically like a great book
you know basically
um that's why i always used to say that
uh the biggest
uh in the supporter of rashdi was always
imam khamenei because his father
actually solved the books made him a
best seller
he made uh stallman a multi-millionaire
but
go back to it so you know you've have
you seen bill maher when he goes and
debates muslim and he goes back and
forth
and he says you know 75 of muslims are
good but 25
of our extremists and i don't know if
you've seen that before when they go
back and forth on that debate
are you are you insinuating or
suggesting that the fact that the
extremists are a byproduct of
post syed and what he wrote pre that
it was a very peaceful religion is that
kind of what you're saying
that things change dramatically after
syed oh no no no definitely not um
first of all islam is not a peaceful
religion let's put this to bed
um you know islam is not a religion of
peace
uh it never was i just said to you
before that there is actually like you
know a jihad conquest
you know in islam basically and the
justification for conquest
um within islam itself um but islam is
not a religion of war either
uh basically you know it is a very
uh what i would call a mercantile
imperial religion
you know so basically it is you know it
basically viewed the conquest of new
lands as an
opportunity for taxation and you know
commerce
so for them they were almost copying the
roman empire
you know basically expansion we need to
expand because we need more citizens so
they pay more tax
we need to expand because basically this
is our this is our commercial destiny
don't forget islam was founded by a
merchant you know prophet muhammed in
fact he started his life as a merchant
um and therefore and islam basically by
the way is one of the most capitalistic
you know free market religions you could
ever find you know the prohibition of
taxation
but you know they you know the opening
of free trade you know that putting uh
tariffs and trade barriers is
anti-islamic you know so basically it is
one of those
you know religions that actually one of
the mottos
of um one of muhammad's disciples when
he arrived to medina
poor and destitute when he was offered
charity he said no no no just show me
where the market is
so this show me where the market is
became a
you know synonymous with islam as a
religion of trade but of course a trade
support with imperial force
um so this is how i could describe islam
in all honesty
you're not you're not just somebody
that's saying that you i don't know how
old you were when you could do this you
memorized every word in the quran right
i was 12 by the time i
uh finished uh the process i started the
age of nine
33 months later basically i finished
memorizing the quran
is that pretty common for uh kids at
that age to memorize the quran i don't
think that's
common right i think one out of twenty
uh at least in my town like you know
basically it was almost one out of five
would do it that's still a big number i
mean in america i don't know if one out
of a thousand kids memorize every word
in the us bible you know
i don't know how many people yeah but i
think the quran is a little bit smaller
than the bible if we put
together the old in the new testament
the quran has about 6
000 um you know 236 verses
um roughly about 143 000 words so
basically it is not that easy to uh
they're not that difficult to memorize
but not that's easy either like you know
basically
yeah so it's still a challenge and
thinking exactly
but let me let me go so let's go back to
osama bin laden so you
hear him speak the guy next to you goes
and
drives the van into the embassy in
nairobi you know lives 150 people are
permanently blind we see this all over
the news i think was 98 i don't know the
exactly when that happened late 90s
and uh at this point you're hearing this
what's next move for you because you
stayed there only for what was it two
years
you know the december of 98 right
december 98th is when you left
so what was the experience like when you
were in there did you ever get close to
him to kind of see how he thinks
osama and then what caused you to want
to leave
i remember when i gave my allegiance to
him and joining al-qaeda
i remember he looked at me and he said
that
he wants me uh to go and uh to
uh become part of al-qaeda's explosives
chemicals uh
explosives chemical and biological
weapon program why
because he said you don't look like the
materials of you know commandos you're
not a commander material you're
not going to be you know someone who
would be carrying heavy weapons and
storming
what's that to him who is the right
material of a commander to him
uh well five foot nine you know and
above i'm five foot seven
um also basically someone who's not
actually wearing glasses all the time
someone basically with a better eyesight
um you know but nonetheless basically
you know he said i see that
you know you have an aptitude for math
and science and
you know you will be the perfect fit for
that i mean so
um so i ended up being sent by him uh to
a remote camp in afghanistan
um you know which was run by an egyptian
uh former officer of the bomb squad in
the egyptian army
um and he was already a veteran of the
afghan jihad he's been there since 1986
um he uh was the master bomb maker in
all of afghanistan and
he was a master in his art so the idea
was is to go
into that remote camp in the mountains
and study with him
so that was for me an eye-opening
experience i mean basically first of all
um only very few people you know make it
into that uh
camp and the reason is because when you
go there there are only four students
each course so the course could run for
seven months
but there are only four people who would
be studying that's it so the camp is
really small
and the reason for the small number is
to limit the possibility of a mistake
the bigger the number of students the
easier it is to have a mistake
and the problem is with making bombs as
anyone will know that your law your
first mistake is your last mistake
that's it no more mistakes to be made
you don't get second chances exactly so
you know so there i've learned you know
uh
the the basics of explosive makings and
then into
you know the bomb making and then into
uh chemical weapons poisons and then
into biological weapons you know it took
about seven eight months
but it was extremely eye-opening you
know for me
and i remember the uh
three people who were studying with me i
had the moroccan a tunisian
the saudi was later years
assistant of zarqawi and was captured by
the americans
his name was hassan gul uh the moroccan
was
you know later captured in morocco in
attempting to blow up synagogues there
uh in
um you know in morocco and then
uh the tunisian who was a pure pure pure
psychopath
um this tunisian guy uh ended up what
was his name what was it tunisian's name
uh his name was
abu nasim that's the alias but his real
name was
he ended up actually masterminding the
uh
terrorist attacks uh on behalf of isis
in tunisia
in recent years the attack in the bardo
museum
and later uh in the uh seuss
beach which killed 31 british tourists
um
so he was the mastermind of these
attacks now
um i would say that you know
you know of out of all the people uh who
were with me
uh in that camp he was the closest to me
i don't know
was i like attracting a psychopath
but and he was the best cook he was you
know he lived in italy so his
faster cooking skills were legendary um
you know and uh you know so we used to
have pasta yes in afghanistan
in the middle of the mountains we used
to have faster you know for
dinners there and while we are busy
learning
in how to make bombs and explosives now
then of course came august of
1998 you know that was a
seminal event in my life because that is
when
that young man who was my friend from
the camp
who came with me to see osama bin laden
and to listen to him
uh two years earlier he uh of course
went on to blow up the american embassy
in nairobi and another guy
then blew up the american embassy in
darussalam tanzania
and simultaneously of course when the
news came to the camps
i mean you know people were saying
rejoice you know the largest cia
station in east africa where bombed to
the ground
and i was thinking okay cia station
that's amazing that's good um
but then of course like many other young
hyder
members i have a radio so i have a radio
and i was listening
you know to one of the radio stations
from the arab world like you know
basically we pick up in the mountains it
was kuwait uh radio
um and also we used to pick up the bbc
arabic so
they said that it was the american
embassies in nairobi in kenya
and darussalam in tanzania so i thought
that's you know okay um one minute here
why are we bombing embassies uh that's
one
and then when the news of the identities
of those who were killed
started to come first um
we were told that 12 americans were
killed in addition to about 220
innocent kenyans somalis and other
africans who were there
you know basically to apply for visas to
visit their friends and family or to
study or to do business
in the us so basically and many others
who were there at the wrong place at the
wrong time
i just did not feel right because you
know al qaeda is preparing me
to be the future bomb maker i will be
one of those who will be building one of
these giant devices
that will go into a van that will do
exactly this
you know it dawned on me more than any
of the others
in the camps because they are just foot
soldiers however i'm the bomb maker
of the future i'm the one who is going
to build this
and kill these people and i will be
meeting god on the day of judgment
with their blood on my hand you know
basically and they will be asking him
you know ask this you know dude here why
did he kill us
so why did he build the device that
actually ended our lives and ended uh
you know our dreams you know so for me
like
i mean that epiphany that moment was so
you know strong and powerful powerful
enough to question
my whole existence within that framework
within al-qaeda
and i remember i went to the
uh de facto mufti of al-qaeda at the
time the religious
you know advisor he is egyptian his name
is
abdullah muhajur and he himself was
involved in the attack or another
embassy three years earlier
the egyptian embassy in islamabad when
it was raised to the ground by a suicide
bomber he had
a hand in that operation too so i went
to ask him
i said look i'm not doubting i just want
my heart to be at peace here
remember you know abdullah
one day i will be building a device like
this so could you please
help me understand how i can justify it
so he said look you know the embassy
was actually a front for the cia
okay that i got that's fine what else
what about the people basically who were
there he said ah look
we have a fatwa in our islamic theology
that when the enemy is hiding within
civilian populated areas we have the
right
to attack and then those civilians who
died
uh the result of our action then god
will
make it up to them in other words
they know the famous saying of kill them
and god will sort them out
um you know i said okay fine you know
where where do you find this pathway he
told me where to find it you know which
is
in uh the comprehensive works of eben
damian which is a scholar living
700 years ago and i thought goodness
that's 37 volumes god help me like
do i find it but anyway i asked him i
said
isn't it you know awful that 220
innocent people you know basically you
know
died because so to get the 12 americans
so he said to me ah come on they were
just bunch of africans who cares
um i looked at him and i said
should you tell that to the somalis in
our camp here
you know they wouldn't take it nicely he
said oh no no no second thought just
don't tell them uh yeah casual racism
was
what gradual actually it was outrageous
racism also exists within al-qaeda can
you believe it even within a time that
we were racist against each other
the saudis against the egyptians the
algerians against the egyptians and
saudis
you know and the tunisians hated each
every every single one of them and the
yemenis were always described as
ignorant mountain monkeys yes you know
it was always like this
you know islamic solidarity seriously
anyway
so so i went
how many other how many other guys at
that time are feeling the same way
you're feeling were there other people
coming up to you were you the only
person that was uh
second guessing everything
i went to the library of al-qaeda in
kabul they have a massive library there
for their islamic sharia courses and so
i searched for that fatwa in that
book i found it um and
no resemblance whatsoever it was talking
about a very completely different
you know era it took it talks about the
uh
mongol invasion of the hawari's mid
persian empire
you know and how the mongols had a
practice where
when they sack a a city
in the muslim world at the time they
will take some civilians from that city
they will make them push the siege
towers the mongol siege towers
towards the walls of the next muslim
city they intend to suck
and of course the muslim defenders have
a dilemma here
do we shoot arrows and spears at those
poor civilians who are being uh coerced
into pushing the sich tower towards our
walls
or not so they sent urgent requests for
petwas and the petwas came back
look they are already dead whether you
kill them by your own hands or
by the mongol hands when they are once
they are done with them
so defend yourselves kill them to
prevent the sich towers from coming
into your walls now
can you see here any resemblance between
that fatwa
and how they actually applied it in the
case of the american embassies in
nairobi and
uh i mean i'm sorry but i didn't see the
american embassy in nairobi pushing
siege towers towards mecca or medina
yeah yeah i mean at that point you know
that's that's kind of how
you know when when uh certain pastors
interpret the bible scripture in their
own way to
manipulate some audiences and these are
when uh
they go away from the bible and they you
want to create their own church and i'm
the
you see this a lot of time with some
people doing that to be able to win
people over
but go back to it so
that even takes place you said that's
that's august 98
i just you know the you still are there
for four more months
during those four more months that
you're there are you being recruited by
mi6
are you gathering intel are you like i
don't know how to leave this place i'm
afraid to leave
what if they kill me maybe i still want
to stick around what are you thinking
for those four months before you left
actually i was i was waiting for my uh
departure date
um so by september you know
roughly about like i mean uh
four weeks after the incident i made my
mind after i read the fatwa after of
course the
cruise missile attack against our camps
you know by president clinton
i decided that i don't want to be part
of this anymore
one day they will tell me to build a
device like this
it's inevitable i don't want to be
the author of death of many innocent
people
who i will never meet i would never know
who they are and now always wondering in
the back of my mind
you know that when my death dates come
i will be facing them in the afterlife
no thank you i don't want to be in that
position
so i decided to leave the problem is
i already have a departure date for a
medical checkup
in qatar it was an important medical
check-up because a year earlier i had
been struck by both malaria and typhoid
at the same time
and that caused some damage to the liver
so the hospital in qatar that treated me
because there wasn't enough you know
advanced
medical facilities in afghanistan and
pakistan at the time
they told me you have to come back in a
year time exactly to make sure that
there is no damage or no lasting damage
so i decided that i have to use that but
the problem is
that date is december 8th
and between september you know and
you know december you know there are few
months but i have to stay there i have
no other choice
you know to wait for the departure date
which is allocated for me
so therefore i waited but i wasn't
waiting
doing nothing i ended up actually like
you know subconsciously
you know uh gathering a lot of uh
information
copying some of the floppy disks ah
floppy disks now for the
millennials who are listening floppy
disks are ancient tools where we can
store
data and information and they were three
half inches by three and a half inches
i think and you know i don't know how
much we can store on them two or three
megabytes i can't remember anyway
nothing nothing
so so i gathered few uh floppy disks
which contained the entire alkali the
program
on explosives bomb making chemical
weapons explode
you know uh biological weapons poisons i
gathered it all basically there and i
also basically
applied myself to study on the map all
the locations of the camps of the places
of the
uh you know uh houses why are you doing
that why are you doing that at that time
are you thinking vengeance
are you thinking i'm going to stop these
guys are you thinking i'm going to go to
somebody with this information why are
you gathering that intel
i think it was for me insurance policy
i got you yeah because i i wasn't
leaving afghanistan to become a spy he
let me you know put it this way i wasn't
leaving to become a spy
i was leaving to go back to university
and
to study history and then to become a
history teacher
that was my dream which was a naive
dream um
now much to the delight and the relief
of my would-be students it never
happened
uh so you know i left the qatar i
arrived there
you know only to be actually detained by
the qatari intelligence they were
waiting for me
and you know and they were aware of my
arrival
thanks to a tip by the french
intelligence how did they know i have no
idea
so you know once i was there
i was you know of course like basically
interrogated at the
in the first 45 minutes basically they
were trying to be intimidated
you know the qatari intelligence uh
officials you know they were trying to
be really intimidating and trying to
scare me and whatever
and what they found from my side was a
very cooperative
and you know you know friendly
you know individual so that's when they
switched on the lights
you know because of course it was dark
at my side and you know they
you know they switched on the lights and
i can see their faces now
and they were telling me what's going on
here why are you being so
you know nice and friendly and you know
you know so i said well you know maybe
you caught me at the right time
basically actually i came here because i
was leaving
and i explained to them the whole thing
as i explained it to you now
so they said okay one minute so they
left the room
in all five six of them and then you
know i think they were discussing
something minutes later they came back
and they all came back to shake my hand
and to hug me so tight and to say well
done
you know well done we believe you so now
we have a lot of questions for you would
you be willing to answer
and they are coming from a western
intelligence service of course
later i was told it was the french
regarding a specific individual a
specific plot a specific
you know incident so i was happy to
supply them with all the information
they needed it was groundbreaking as far
as they understand
um and they said to me by the end of the
nine days
i was their guest of course the
treatment was amazing you know basically
i ended up basically being caught
meals from the nearby five-star hotel of
the sheraton
um you know to make it you know to make
my
stay comfortable but then they told me
that
we know that you want to go to a normal
life but we can't offer you this
qatar qatar at that time it was 1998
it was as in it was a city of 250 000
people
you will be meeting many of your friends
on daily basis you will just run into
them in the mosques and the supermarkets
and
you know wherever you go i mean and so
it's not safe for you here
we suggest that you are better protected
if you are to go under the protection
of a larger country
a more powerful agency that will
you know make use of you but at the same
time protect you
um i said okay and
who do you have in mind they said well
of course the french are extending their
you know warm welcome uh because they
already
been hearing you via video link you know
for the past nine days
um and also there are the british
and the americans so
i said okay and how long do i have to
make up my mind
you know basically like in a day or two
no 30 minutes
so 30 minutes to make up my mind and so
i remember i
you know sat down thought to myself you
know basically
if the dear lord got me out of
afghanistan
into here into the lab of the you know
intelligence services and i already
trusted in his judgment
if this is his judgment so be it
um i decided not the french
i don't want to learn another language
and i'm not exactly very fond of them to
begin with
um then
you know the americans you know i just
survived their cruise missile attack
just few months ago i can't just
you know you know be lovey-dovey with
someone who just you know basically
press the button to kill me just few
months ago um
however the british there is an affinity
my grandfather fought for the british in
iraq
in 1915 um and in later life i realized
basically that my father worked for the
uk foreign office possibly intelligence
services in the 1960s and 70s so
that was a you know a revelation that i
didn't expect
um and then of course
um you know i decided well there is
affinity with the british already i've
been to london before
there is some familiarity there so i
chose you know basically to go
and work with the uh british
intelligence services
so that night boarded the plane
uh british airways flight and i flew to
london
once you got there how soon did they
find
out that you're with mi6 if not while
you're there for years
and if they did find out did anybody
reach out to you
were you ever worried was your life ever
threatened were you living a peaceful
life what happened next
well of course uh mi6 was amazing at uh
concocting a cover story for my arrival
the qatari hospital in qatar
decided that my situation is
life-threatening that they need to
send me to a hospital in the uk so they
flew me there
you know under the pretense and once i'm
there you know
a hospital room was ready for me and i
invited some of my friends
who were based in london to come and see
me so they can see for real basically
that i was
you know basically hospitalized um and
paid for by the qatari embassy
uh that all you know basically uh
laid the appeals and then it was by the
invitation
of members of al-qaeda in london that i
stayed in london
basically for the foreseeable future in
order to help them with
lots of things including recruitment
fundraising and other
uh activities so suddenly it's like the
effort by mi6 paid off but the idea was
that i'm supposed to be in london for
two months for debriefings
you know so the debriefing of mi6 about
everything that i knew
including the you know the maps and the
floppy disks basically that i brought
with me the data on
al-qaeda's activities and bomb-making
and explosive and chemical weapons and
everything
else uh that debriefing lasted seven
months
you know i didn't know i had so much
knowledge in my head but it turns out to
be
you know the case like you know i knew
so much so the idea is
you know i was told i remember i arrived
it was um
the you know the i think 16th or 17th of
december
when i arrived in london it was just
christmas
you know about to uh you know to come
the week after the you know the mi5 and
my six counter terrorism officers who
greeted me said
you know you know christmas you know
came very early this year you know uh we
didn't know that
you know santa come dressed in a beard
like yours
so you know that was a
wonderful thing to hear of course you
know um
when i arrived there the
british intelligence services both mi5
and mi6
were just starting to recruit more and
more
from their internal offices and other
departments into the
counter-terrorism until nairobi and
tanzania
um attacks the uh mi6 was focusing on
the former soviet union republics the
proliferation of nuclear materials you
know the gun running out of the ukraine
and other places
uh counter-espionage you know all of
that thing
uh mi5 was focusing on the ira you know
the
irish terrorism um and organized crime
and the mafia coming out of russia so
there was
you know uh that was their focus so
basically suddenly
you know the uh offices of islamic
counterterrorism within mr5 and mi6 need
to swell
their rights and i came
at the same time you know the same time
frame so
for me they were bringing more and more
of their analysts to every meeting in
order to learn to study to understand
you know and so to you know so basically
it was the timing
of my arrival i think basically that you
know at later years i was told that
i did make a difference you know they
always used to tell me that
your the timing of your arrival made a
lot of difference
it was just the right time when we are
about you know to recruit more and more
people from within the ranks
you know they needed a crash course
immediately basically on what's
happening
you were the right you know i won't say
guinea pig you know but
you know you were the right person to
come at the right time in order to
explain it all
um and at the time i was only 20.
how long did you stay with mi6 until i
was 28
eight years eight years you were with
them so
uh now you're still in uk today uh yes
no death threats i mean they tried twice
you know i already had the football on
my head in 2008.
um and uh you know there were um
uh you know two attempts of my life once
in 2009
in london and another which was a
serious one actually
it was in 2016 in bahrain
um that was supposed to coincide with
the 15th anniversary of 2011.
um so yeah i mean basically like you
know it's not uh
plain sailing but at the same time um
you know i'm not exactly like
i mean uh afraid at the end of the day
if i was
uh willing to sacrifice my life for the
wrong you know cause
it would be extremely hypocritical of me
you know if i'm to be
a coward and working for the right cause
what a mindset to have
what a mindset to have to know that you
go through that where
it becomes normal to be a martyr to give
your life to something
but at that time you don't believe in it
but still it influences you
so much that one day you will accept the
fact that you're willing to give your
life
to something of a positive and good
makes it a little bit more
like it almost desensitizes you to it
but god it's not a big deal if i'm
giving it up for the right reasons i'll
do it i don't know if a lot of people
are going to go through that
desensitization if that's even a war to
go through it
joe so let me let me change the
direction of the conversation here we'll
wrap up
this has been great is
from the outside looking in you're in uk
you know one question is just for me
personally you know
you mentioned something about khomeini
and he was doing the tapes when he was
in france and he was sending it in and
putting the taxis and everybody would
listen to it and
he caused a revolution the shot fell etc
etc are you aware
of who were the political prisoners that
he had
the 3000 political prisoners that he had
when jimmy carter was forcing him
because he was he was campaigning on
human rights and he wanted the shot to
let go of the political prison
prisoners that he had in iran some of
them were today which i don't know if
you're familiar with today is the
communists at that time but was was and
were any of the people that he had there
individuals that later on ended up
causing 911
that the political prisoners in iran or
you're not aware of it
uh between you and me i'm not aware of
it the only
yeah the only person i'm aware basically
that you know more or less had
uh provided help and logistics like you
know for al qaeda
in afghanistan and
enabling some of the drug trade to go
through sustainability
you know from the afghan border was uh
the
leader of the puts force qasim suleimani
which they later took out under trump
so you you you know from the outside
looking into u.s
what do you see happening in u.s i mean
you've been around the block for a while
you know does u.s in where you are you
uk when you're watching bbc
i know you watch cnn as well because you
mentioned cnn
what is your interpretation of where
america is at right now
well what is what worries me and you
remember i
talked about the civil wars in
yugoslavia
clearly that's why i'm asking the
question i remember when you said that
yeah i
always worry when people of different
political and religious
and ideological persuasions start to
view
the other side as the enemy so much you
know there is
um a word you know or a phrase
attributed to the prophet muhammad
which says that love your friends
moderately
for they may become your enemies one day
and detest your enemies moderately
for they may become your friends one day
moderation is the key to the longevity
of nations
and you know no matter how much
who said this that's the prophet
muhammad
you know moderation is you know the key
to the longevity of nations we can't
have a situation where the left hate the
right so much they will call them nazis
and you know the right hate the left so
much
that they will see them as subversive
communists you know
uh revolutionaries i mean there has to
be that middle ground
somewhere where we all can meet and
agree on something
while at the same time you know when we
moderate our positions on the left and
on the right
then we can guarantee the longevity and
the coexistence between all of these
factions for the benefit of the greater
good what is the greater good in my
opinion the nation state
i always you know
get asked the question who are you loyal
to
you know islam the uk saudi arabia
bahrain i say no i am loyal to the
nation state
to the nation state wherever that nation
state may be as long as they adhere to
the basic principles of the nation state
with the institutions of the nation
state judicial
you know and otherwise in order to
maintain
you know prosperity uh stability
security law and order you know for
everyone
you know the civil war that we have in
islam right now
is actually between factions who want to
destroy the modern nation state
and the modern nation state we have the
sunni
political islam the muslim brotherhood
they want to bring down the nation state
you know we have the militant sunni
islam
al-qaeda you know whatever they want to
bring down the nation state
we have the political and militant shia
islam
they want to bring down the nation
states all for the sake of a
borderless you know superstructure of
islamic empire they want to revive based
on
fictional ideas of al mahdi a messiah
and whatever basically which doesn't
exist
it's a fabrication from islamic history
the reality is there is no escaping
the fact that the only guarantor of
safety security stability law and order
is that nation state
and you can't have a nation state if
you always have people who on the right
always
detest the government and its
institutions and it's
you know basically principle uh a duty
in protecting
citizens or on the left who basically
say
no borders no nations that's it just you
know basically
defund the police no more you know
basically uh nation state institutions
we have this problem we need to bring
both
fringes down a notch or two
in order basically to ensure the
survival of the nation-state
because many of those who oppose the
nation-state either on the right or the
left did not see
what i saw when i spent six years of my
life in four different war zones
where i saw what the collapse of the
nation state means
no atm outside to get your cash you know
no
safety no security no fire brigade no
police force
in only warlords who would rape your
women and children only
you know people who would steal your
food you know under and you don't think
about survival until the next five years
when you graduate no
you think about survival for the next
five days sometimes even five hours or
five minutes
that is why young millennials you know
in the states
need to take a breath and read some
history books
about what a collapse of the nation
state really means
what a powerful last 45 seconds what you
just said
i wish we had more time together i got
to tell you i've enjoyed this
uh i was told about this interview uh
two hours before you and i sat down
together you know the story already i
told you off the record what took place
but yeah
i am so glad we did this interview today
i really enjoyed talking to you and i
hope the right people that watch this
it'll also get them to question
certain mindsets they have and certain
ways that we can all improve to uh
become a little bit more civil than
divided as we are right now in the u.s
anyways having said that we're going to
put the links below to both of your
books once again
thank you so much for making the time to
be a guest on valuetainment thank you so
much thank you for having me
pleasure al qaeda to mi6 what a story
did you notice every time i'd ask
questions he can go
deeper and deeper and deeper in some of
the answers he made here's your note
your takeaway comment below if you
enjoyed it press the thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel
i got two other interviews for you to
consider one of them is with
hamudi jasim who was part of the iraqi
army i think he was the youngest
sergeant major that they had and then he
became a spy
turned on them if you not see it and
click over here and the other one is a
story of latif
yaya who was saddam hussein's sons
double and he had a chance to be around
him and the stories he tells
is mind-boggling if you want to be
entertained click over here with that
being said have a good one everybody
take care bye